it's high-level week at the United
Nations General Assembly where world
leaders highlight humanity's biggest
challenges human rights are universal
and indivisible one cannot pick and
choose favouring some wild is raining
others but the headlines are all about
the political woes of US president
Donald Trump and British prime minister
Boris Johnson and that means it's harder
for the public to know what UN delegates
are doing namely trying to reveal the
countless ways in which people are
fighting for their rights and to improve
their lives as Bolivian President Evo
Morales addressed the General Assembly
his political opponents railed against
him outside the hall she is lying to the
world he came here to lie to the wall
saying that everything everything is
under control
and it's not that's why we demand the
people from the world to help us
meanwhile the US has made ending
religious persecution a key part of its
foreign policy it and the United Kingdom
convened a session highlighting China's
abuse of Weger Muslims
I cried out Allah oh the day the guard
said tell Allah to save you from my hand
officials debated how to stop Beijing's
behavior we urged the UN to investigate
and closely monitor China's human rights
abuses including the repression of
religious freedom and belief the
responsibility primarily entails their
prevention of such crimes other meetings
focused on Syria's lost generation after
millions fled civil war the political
crisis in Venezuela and how it's
affecting the lives of its people and
the ongoing crisis involving the rahaga
of Myanmar human rights groups say
something is lost when the UN's work is
ignored we have to move to a culture
within the UN system that people
recognize that
on every issue that humanity confronts
there's been enough talk this is without
a doubt the biggest week on the UN's
calendar with so many humanitarian
crises being discussed and debated it's
pretty obvious that much of the world
still considers this place a force for
change
Rosalind Jordan al Jazeera the United
Nations